[Musique]
et comme tous les lundis miquel et demi
d'euro bonds soir sans grégory
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
de tv 78 pour nous faire un panorama des
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end du rugby pour commencer miquel
on va parler de division d'honneur lui
verser 60 18 n'est pas passé loin d'une
victoire lui versé 78 rock j fois
c'était le choc de milieu de tableau de
division honneur et ce match a tenu
toutes ses promesses après une grosse
bataille dans la possession le stade
roger couderc de montigny le bretonneux
a finalement vu les visiteurs s'imposer
dans les derniers instants du match
score final 18 à 17
rageant forcément pour les saint
quentinois en écoute les réactions à
chaud c'est pas compliqué ils ont fait
un très beau match
ils ont joué comme il fallait à
l'extérieur ils ont réussi à prendre le
score et derrière ils ont des bons
angles human qui ont bien joué et bien
bien géré bien gérer les temps forts
temps faibles et du coup bas à la fin ça
joue à rien mais c'est pour eux je
pouvais pas un mauvais match en est fier
qu'on se crée les occasions pour pour
aller au bout il ya eu plein de petites
erreurs dans des zones de marque qui
nous coûte cher parce que l'arrivée on
aura un point alors qu'on aurait dû
beaucoup plus scoré pour pour faire
moins active aux deux équipes
donc effectivement c'est en fait une
belle prestation et on a failli passer à
la trappe à d'ailleurs les dernières
minutes
ces minutes de la fin donc mais on n'a
pas perdu pied en étant jusqu'à la fête
jusqu'au bout de la concentration de la
lucidité pour aller rechercher les
points qu'il fallait malgré cette
défaite lui verser 60 18 prend le point
de bonus défensif les saint quentinois
se retrouve 3e du championnat et 23
points et 5 victoires depuis le début de
la saison un bilan inattendue après huit
journées pour ce nouveau club issu d'une
fusion entre le sky rugby et
montigny-le-bretonneux
il était très positif avant le match un
peu moins aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est une fusion si donc un
groupe est en train de se créer donc
c'est aussi des matches comme ça qui
nous permet de renforcer ce groupe
l'objectif c'était sportif à la base on
se prend un petit peu au jeu maintenant
et finir dans les quatre premiers
ça va être dur mais faut être ambitieux
prochain match pour lui rc 60,18 le
dimanche celui décembre sur le terrain
de l'ani une équipe de bas de tableau de
division honneur du football pour
continuer ça va mieux pour trappe
troisième match sans défaite pour trappe
dans le championnat de régionale 2
trappe jouer ce week-end contre livrés à
domicile et les trappistes ont regagné 1
à 0 devant leurs supporters cette
troisième victoire de la saison permet
au joueur dit chardy de reprendre espoir
dans la course à la montée
les trappistes son 9e sur 12 équipes
engagées prochain match contre
versailles pour le derby évinois le 15
décembre prochain toujours à domicile et
on termine par du basket un résultat de
nationale 3 9e journée trappe s'est
imposé 79 à 77 face à fécampois sur son
parquet de son côté le chesnay
versailles s'est imposée 74 56 à
domicile au classement on retrouve les
deux équipes évinoise dans le top 5 le
chesnay versailles est deuxième à un
petit point de la première place ces
trois points à la quatrième place du
classement
la 10e journée est programmée le
week-end prochain merci michael ces
résultats et bien d'autres encore à
retrouver dans quelques minutes sur tv
78 de votre émission
le s et huit sports